les dessins animés et constitue
aujourd'hui l'un des secteurs les plus
rentables du cinéma à l'image du dernier
tarzan de disney les produits dérivés
inondent le marché
un filon qui a surtout profité jusqu'à
présent au studio américain mercredi
sort sur les écrans princesse mononoké
un grand dessin animé japonais dont
l'ambition est de chatouiller l'ogre
américain
tyrus thomas fleurs denis bassompierre
seul à sa table de travail
il ya en bien ça qui veut réalisateur
mime les scènes de son film princesse
mononoké une grande épopée de 2h15
immense succès au japon le parcours
initiatique de ce jeune prince est le
premier dessin animé japonais a
bénéficié d'une sortie mondiale d'une
telle ampleur car depuis 20 ans bande
dessinée et séries télé japonaise
appelée tous deux mangas ont
familiariser les enfants avec ses
personnages dont les visages sont
d'ailleurs très peu japonais souvent
décrié par les parents pour leur
violence
les mangas ans des millions de fans et
les magasins spécialisés se multiplier
en france
les mets des françaises ils ont un gros
nez tout comme assez riche et ça vaut
mieux suivre sexe violence et sans
reproche tout le temps mais en fait
milliard il n'y a pas que ça croyez
vraiment accès venir ici et découvrir un
petit peu vraiment la psychologie des
personnages est plus fouillée qui a
donné les ordres
l'excellente mais tout cela sera-t-il
suffisant pour rivaliser avec les
studios américains tout puissant comme
disney pour y parvenir les japonais
puise dans la formidable richesse des
légendes de leur passé et dans un
rapport poétique et presque charnel avec
les forces de la nature
à chaque occasion en solitaire à la
nature
chaque fête c'est la fête lié avec une
quelque chose des éléments de nature
comme une jument trouve une foule
cette guerre a trop duré vous pourriez
vivre en paix avec les humains
même s'il dispose des technologies les
plus avancées mis à sakhir est un
véritable auteur dont la philosophie
entraînent chaque image de son film
s'opposant ainsi au modèle américain
beaucoup plus anonyme reste le problème
des produits dérivés qui financièrement
et en terme d'image constitue le
véritable nerf de la guerre
et dans ce domaine hollywood ne cèdera
pas facilement sa place
supprimée mais jusqu'au dernier